et notre invité ce matin c'est Mathieu
Palin bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes auteur de ce livre nos
pères nos frères nos amis c'est aux
éditions Les Arènes c'est une galerie de
portraits ça parle évidemment des
violences conjugales auteur de violences
victimes famille de victimes soignants
et plusieurs autres portraits de 4 ans
que vous avez faites basées sur ces
rencontres une immersion dans des
groupes de paroles pour les hommes
violents vous avez choisi un autre angle
pour aborder cette question des
violences conjugales vous cherchez à
comprendre qui sont les hommes violents
comment ils en sont arrivés là est-ce
que si on veut éradiquer ce fléau de la
violence conjugale la première étape
selon vous c'est de savoir ce que ces
hommes ont dans la tête
et surtout de sortir d'une vision un peu
monstrueuse de l'homme violent qui
serait forcément l'autre qui serait
forcément quelqu'un de d'absolument
maléfique et qui ne nous ressemblent pas
alors que les chiffres sont là et les
chiffres nous montrent que sur 220 000
plaintes chaque année de femmes qui se
disent victimes de violences conjugales
les experts pensent qu'on peut
facilement multiplier le chiffre par
quatre ou cinq pour avoir le vrai
chiffre des violences ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les violences conjugales
sont sous-estimées dans notre pays très
largement très très largement déjà parce
que toutes les victimes ne portent pas
plein parce qu'il est difficile de
porter plainte parce que parfois ne
serait-ce que d'aller dans le
commissariat et porter plainte c'est
compliqué dans le livre il y a plusieurs
femmes qui témoignent et qui racontent
n'avoir tout simplement pas pu alors
qu'elle voulait porter plainte donc en
réalité les combien ce chiffre pour vous
plutôt autour du million d'hommes
violents dans ce pays et c'est à la fois
rassurant et à la fois très inquiétant
de se dire que il y a pas un million de
monstres dans ce pays mais plutôt des
gens comme nous des des pères des frères
des amis des des gens qui ne ressemblent
et qui sont très insérés dans la société
et vous le dites dans votre livre c'est
220 000 mecs violents ce ne sont pas 220
000 Mons de 120 000 bêtes féroces qui
sillonnent aux rues à la recherche d'une
proie facile ce serait si simple ça veut
dire que c'est pas facilité qu'on
cherche à en faire des monstres non je
pense que c'est assez c'est assez
naturel en fait je le j'ai beaucoup
travaillé par exemple sur les questions
carcérales et de détention c'est vrai
que quand on parle des détenus des
prisonniers c'est la même chose on
s'imagine toujours que c'est l'autre et
que ça pourra jamais nous arriver et
est-ce que quelque part ça nous rassure
peut-être aussi d'en entrer inconscient
de se dire que ce sont des monstres et
que du coup ça ne peut pas être celui
qu'on connaît
je pense assez naturel qui permet de
continuer à se regarder dans une glace
de dire ça me concerne pas et même ceux
qui savent
qu'ils ont une violence entre eux en eux
se disent bon bah ça va moi il y a pas
mort d'homme il y a pas mort de il y a
pas j'ai tué personne et et je pense que
c'est justement là le problème c'est que
des hommes qui s'il regardait leur vécu
avec un peu de
d'autocritique se rendre compte qu'en
fait il y a un problème et que le
rapport de domination sur la sur les
femmes ils l'ont quand bien même ils
n'ont jamais levé la main sur aucune
femme donc c'est un livre qui est aussi
essaye de questionner la manière avec
laquelle on régit les rapports
homme-femmes aussi comme on élève les
petits garçons les petites filles pour
justement
pardon pour cette question qui peut
paraître un peu provoque mais est-ce
qu'il existe des hommes violents
sympathiques
il y en a plein de la même manière qu'il
existe des gens sympas gentils et
violents moi j'en ai rencontré beaucoup
et j'ai passé
de quatre ans en immersion auprès de Dom
violents et de femmes aussi victimes
avec qui j'ai eu plaisir aussi à
discuter à boire des bières à à rire
aussi et pour autant dans les minutes
qui suivaient je les entendais proférer
des des horreurs sur leur ex-compagne et
c'est pas pour autant que je faisais pas
la barre des choses donc c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui justement c'est un ressort
psychologique c'est à dire il y a une
forme de dualité dans leur esprit ou
c'est un comportement à la maison et un
comportement en société ça dépend il
faut pas généraliser il y a les deux cas
de figure il y a celui qui est violent
tout le temps celui qui dit que il
dégaine vite qui dégoupille qu'il faut
pas trop le pousser
un nerveux ça c'est un profil qui existe
et j'en ai rencontré qui sont violents à
la maison mais ils sont aussi violents
sur le parking quand vous leur voulez à
la place de devant le supermarché ils
sont hyper agressifs dans la rue dans le
métro dans un bar ils sont capables de
se battre un peu pour tout et n'importe
quoi et puis il y a aussi des profils
d'hommes qui sont très gentils très
calme souriants qui jamais un peu un mot
plus haut que l'autre mais qui sont
extrêmement violents dans le cercle de
la famille et qui sont eux
insoupçonnables et ces deux cas de
figure on les rencontre presque à
égalité et vous expliquer dans votre
livre que ça ne touche pas uniquement
les classes sociales défavorisées ça
peut être peut-être un cliché c'est pas
du tout le cas vous parlez de femmes
médecins de journalisme de notables et
qui ne porte pas plainte en raison de la
honte sociale est-ce que les ressorts
psychologiques ils sont différents selon
la classe sociale à laquelle on
appartient
il y a ça et puis il y a aussi le fait
que quand vous habitez dans un immeuble
et qui est une certaine promiscuité que
dans un HLM tout le monde sait que la
femme qui habite au 4e est victime de
violence parce qu'on l'entend crier
parce que on entend des hurlements ça
s'engueule beaucoup la femme qui habite
dans un pavillon au bout d'un jardin
dans une résidence assez sécurisée
peut si elle le ciel ne montre pas les
coûts qu'elle subit si on a la pas des
hématomes sur le visage elle peut subir
des violences dans quasiment dans
l'indifférence la plus totale ça veut
dire que ça peut être encore plus dur
pour ces femmes là qui sont d'une classe
sociale élevée parce qu'elles sont plus
isolées
dans les victimes mais en tout cas
il est certain que
l'apparence ce qu'on va dire de soins en
société ça joue beaucoup ça joue et puis
il est en tout cas il est certain que
les hommes qui font partie disons de
cette catégorie sociale là plutôt
favorisée des médecins des kinés
politique aussi
sont moins enclins à rencontrer la
justice moi dans le livre il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de d'hommes que je
rencontre qui sortent de prison avec
lesquels je participe à ce groupe de
responsabilisation
contre la violence
tous les autres hommes que je rencontre
qui sont concernés et qui font justement
partie de ces catégories sociales un peu
plus élevées non pas eu à rencontrer la
justice ont eu très peu de plaintes
contre eux et continuer leur vie
quasiment sans aucun problème donc il y
a aussi cette justice à deux vitesses
qui fait que certains y échappent parce
qu'ils ont un statut social parce que
ils ont une réputation parce que aussi
il y a un déséquilibre financier qui
fait que la femme parfois a du mal à
partir et et là on voit des différences
vous avez évidemment vous êtes mis dans
la tête de ces hommes pendant des années
est-ce qu'ils se rendent compte ces
hommes là que leur comportement n'est
pas normal ou est-ce qu'ils sont dans le
déni complet il y a un déni qui est
assez incroyable
et qui est là dès le début moi j'allais
d'abord dans ces groupes de parole en
imaginant arriver dans un groupe un peu
d'Alcooliques Anonymes de d'hommes qui
dira bonjour je m'appelle Mathieu j'ai
34 ans et je frappe ma femme et le débat
allait pouvoir commencer et en fait
cette phrase là toute simple je frappe
ma femme je l'ai entendu deux fois en
quatre ans et pas forcément une fois
seulement avec un homme qui était dans
ses groupes là le déni sur ce qu'ils ont
fait il est énorme et je pense qu'il est
aussi lié malgré tout à une société qui
est en train de changer et à ce
mouvement Mitou qui a pris de l'ampleur
parce que ce dernier dans leur bouche il
était très souvent suivi par une phrase
du style de toute manière maintenant
avec la justice les femmes
les femmes ont repris le pouvoir avec
Mitou elles ont renversé la table et
elles veulent se venger donc en gros
nous on a rien fait mais on est les
victimes de cette inversion des rôles
est-ce que vous dites dans votre livre
c'est que ces hommes qui sont coupables
de violences conjugales ils se sentent
eux-mêmes victimes oui ça c'est très
classique dans les dans les cas de
violences conjugales d'avoir une
inversion de la culpabilité et des
victimes qui elles se sentent coupables
de ce qui est arrivé du fait que les
enfants ne puissent plus voir le père
qu'il est connu la prison que donc il y
a une inversion totale des rôles et pour
autant je pense que leur incapacité à
dire c'est vrai je l'ai fait je suis là
pour parce que j'ai un problème de
violence et j'aimerais bien le régler
pour ne pas avoir à reconnaître la garde
à vue la justice
elle est aussi liée au fait qu'ils sont
pas fiers d'avoir frappé leur femme ils
sont pas capables de le dire comme on
pouvait l'entendre peut-être il y a 50
ou 60 ans oui je l'ai frappé et puis
elle le méritait et d'ailleurs j'espère
bien qu'elle va pas recommencer parce
que sinon
on l'entend plus alors que bah la norme
qui voulait que l'homme chef de famille
était un peu
capable de pas de vie ou de mort mais
quasiment sur les membres de sa famille
que ce soit sa femme ou ses enfants
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
maintenant largement remis en question
et eux aussi sont conscients de ça
est-ce que vous parlez du mouvement MiTo
est-ce que ça a eu un effet sur la prise
de conscience chez ces hommes qu'ils
étaient auteurs de violences conjugales
je sais pas si ça a eu un effet sur
cette prise de conscience parce que
justement elle est difficile on voit que
c'est un processus qui est très long et
la remise en question elle demande aussi
on parle beaucoup de déconstruction en
ce moment elle demande parfois de
remettre en question toute une éducation
parfois des hommes de 50 à 55 60 ans à
qui on dit en fait monsieur votre
comportement il est pas du tout OK et
tout ce que vous tout ce qui a amené à
ce que vous frapper votre femme en fait
il faut le remettre en question toute
votre structure mentale presque donc
c'est très difficile mais le mouvement
mis tout comme parce que c'est
intéressant il y a un cycle de violences
conjugales
aussi d'une éducation chez eux il y a
une reproduction de ces violences
conjugales la violence c'est pas quelque
chose avec laquelle vous naissez c'est
pas un gène comme on peut y avoir le
gène de la trisomie c'est c'est un
comportement qu'on apprend en y étant
exposé quand vous grandissez dans un
foyer où ça se crie dessus toute la
journée et vous voyez votre père tirer
votre mère par les cheveux la traînée
sur le parquet ça des traces ça marque
le cerveau aussi et il y a une
des chances ou des risques beaucoup plus
grands ensuite de répéter soit processus
de mise en danger ou tout simplement des
comportements violents et ces hommes là
parfois il est enfin on voit qu'il est
difficile aussi de remettre en question
la manière avec laquelle on a été éduqué
et aussi un modèle de virilité qu'ils
ont suivi un peu en se disant bah voilà
c'est c'est ce modèle là que je vais
suivre pour devenir un homme et là on
leur dit mais en fait vous avez rien
compris ce modèle là c'est celui qui
vous a emmené en prison et c'est très
très compliqué à remettre en question
votre livre il interroge aussi le modèle
de société qu'on ces hommes dans leur
tête et leur vision de la femme vous
citez des exemples d'un homme qui dit à
sa femme regarde la maison il te manque
rien
je rentre le soir il y a rien qui est
prêt je me suis je me suis marié pour
qu'on fasse des omelettes et un autre
homme qui dit elle s'occupe en parlant
de sa femme préoccupe pas bien de la
maison je rentre et il y a pas à manger
faut qu'elle prenne ses responsabilités
de femmes et qu'elle fasse à manger
les violences conjugales chez certains
c'est aussi du purematisme vision qu'ils
ont de la femme qui est pourrie
inférieure les deux exemples que vous
citez sont sont vraiment liés à une
vision du couple qui est très ancienne
et aussi une incompréhension face au
changement et de des femmes qui
travaillent qui gagnent leur vie et qui
disent bah non c'est je suis plus là
pour je suis plus t'abonner je suis plus
là pour ramasser tes chaussettes et pour
faire les courses et puis les deux
devoirs des gamins et tout et eux ont
l'impression de répéter de manière assez
logique le schéma qu'ils ont connu quand
ils étaient enfants avec une mère au
foyer qui s'occupait de tout tout tout
et un père qui rapportait de l'argent à
la maison et mais c'est quand même pas
la majorité des hommes rencontrés et il
y en a beaucoup qui mais je pense qu'on
est tous concernés là à ce niveau là qui
répète aussi un schéma assez assez
lambda assez partagé qui est de dire que
l'homme puisqu'il est le chef de famille
depuis des siècles pourquoi est-ce que
arriver eux dans un couple ce serait pas
encore le cas et ça c'est quelque chose
qui vient justement
en résonance avec le mouvement Mewtwo et
qui est source aussi de
d'incompréhension il y a beaucoup de ces
hommes je sentais qu'ils étaient un peu
perdus face à cette société en train de
changer ça les angoisse cette évolution
de la société ça les angoisse parce
qu'il la comprennent pas forcément et
quand en plus pour la plupart d'entre
eux je parle pour ceux qui ont connu la
justice qui est la petite frange des
hommes qui ont été condamnés pour
violence conjugale et bien entendu pas
tous les hommes eux ont l'impression du
coup on ne vision un peu
faussée de la réalité parce qu'ils
disent nous on a été on a été condamné
et on a été condamné dans ce mouvement
dans ce mouvement me too qui dit en gros
les hommes il faut qu'ils changent et ça
ils ont presque une bonne raison de se
présenter comme des victimes il voit ce
mouvement MiTo qu'un mouvement mondial
qui est comme une espèce de gros nuage
noir qui flotte au-dessus de leur tête
et ça ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
beaucoup entendu vous parlez aussi des
femmes qui sont victimes et de certaines
attitudes parfois de d'une forme de
dépendance finalement
vous racontez des femmes qui minimisent
les faits d'autres qui vont au parloir
quand leur mari est incarcéré pour leur
apporter du linge alors c'est vrai que
quand on ne connaît pas le problème on a
tendance à se poser la question mais
pourquoi elles font ça c'est très
compliqué de quitter
de quitter quelqu'un que vous aimez dans
dans ces relations il y a aussi des
sentiments et c'est des gens qui se sont
mis en couple parfois de manière
extrêmement sincère c'est pas que des
mariages à rangés c'est et j'ai vu très
souvent c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose
qui est assez qui désempare des
des associations qui accompagnent les
victimes de d'avoir des phénomènes de
retour après avoir été hébergé
accompagnés pendant des semaines des
mois des femmes qui qui malgré tout
reviennent voire celui qui les a frappés
l'homme violent qui qui est encore dans
les parages même quand parfois il y a
des ordonnances de protection qui ont
été prononcées par un juge il faut
plusieurs départs pour aboutir un départ
pour aboutir un départ définitif
une femme qui travaille dans une
association qui me dit que elle elle
l'observe environ 6 ou 7 départs avant
de réussir à partir vraiment et en
général le vrai départ c'est celui qui
qui arrive juste après que la femme
victime et eu l'impression qu'elle
allait y passer et cette peur de mort
imminente qui permet un départ définitif
mais c'est vrai que c'est il y a aussi
le phénomène d'emprise qui est assez qui
est assez présent et que en effet une
jeune femme qui était là pour des faits
multiréidivistes à la barre pour quitter
pour son conjoint violent en lui disant
s'il vous plaît je l'aime il reste de
l'amour ne l'envoyez pas en prison et
puis c'est un bon père c'est des phrases
qu'on entend beaucoup et on aimerait ne
pas les entendre parce qu'on aimerait
que ce soit simple et que la victime
soit dès le premier coup capable de
partir et de plus retourner en arrière
et de plus avoir de lien avec l'homme
violent mais c'est pas forcément comme
ça que ça se passe il y a la question de
l'emprise psychologique que vous nous
écrivez est-ce qu'il y a aussi des
questions matérielles qui empêchent les
femmes de partir il y a une sénatrice
centrise Valérie létharque qui a fait
une proposition de loi pour une aide
universelle pour les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales pour qu'elles
puissent disposer d'argent pour quitter
le foyer violent est-ce que ça c'est une
bonne solution pour vous c'est en France
cette question financière
tout ce qui peut permettre d'être pas la
corde au cou quand on quitte le le
conjoint qui apporte aussi une aide
financière ça peut que être bénéfique
surtout quand on sait qu'une ordonnance
de protection elle elle permet en
général à la femme de partir avec les
enfants
être avec un seul salaire pour s'occuper
des enfants c'est très problématique de
trouver un appartement quand on a quand
on est parfois dans des situations
précaires de pas avoir de CDI c'est
extrêmement problématique aussi donc une
aide financière je crois que pour
certains elle peut se peut être sous
forme de dons donc ça peut être bien
entendu qu'un
plus remboursé par le conjoint violent
c'est ce qui a dans ce texte donc pour
vous c'est évidemment un plus la lutte
contre les violences conjugales ça a été
fait grande cause nationale mais est-ce
que vous avez vraiment le sentiment que
les politiques ont la bonne approche du
problème
il y a encore peu de temps on entendait
une ministre à l'égalité homme-femme
dire que elle allait quand même pas
dépenser de l'argent pour la prise en
charge des bourreaux alors que elle
avait les associations féministes qui
lui demandaient d'en mettre un peu plus
sur le je trouve que déjà cette vision
hyper manichéenne du problème elle
montre une méconnaissance de la réalité
du terrain c'est-à-dire que si on si on
pense que les hommes violents on va
aller réparer juste en les mettant en
prison sachant qu'en plus en général
c'est des courtes peines et des courtes
peines c'est 22h dans cellule 2 heures
de promenade avec rien au milieu très un
accès très difficile au psychologue donc
c'est je pense c'est un peu croire au
Père Noël aussi donc il faut il faut
mettre des moyens bien entendu pour
accompagner les femmes victimes pour que
elle puisse être indépendant
financièrement qu'elle puisse s'éloigner
définitivement du conjoint violent
qu'elle puisse s'occuper des enfants
mais il faut aussi mettre en place des
choses pour que les hommes ne récidivent
pas et c'est très très on sait que le
taux de récidive en plus c'est
extrêmement élevé si vous remettez pas
en question votre comportement si vous
considérez que en tant qu'homme vous
avez le pouvoir de dominer votre femme
et que vous en avez que ces mêmes
endroits qu'on que vous avez croyez par
une des sectes de domination masculine
on avancera pas je vais revenir
là-dessus ce sera ma dernière question
mais pour finir sur le politique il y a
eu l'affaire cadenas ces derniers temps
Adrien catenens le député qui a été
condamné à quatre mois pour avec sursis
pour violence conjugales il est de
retour dans l'hémicycle est-ce que pour
vous c'est un bon signal qui est envoyé
aux femmes victimes un bon signal non je
dirais pas ça non ce qui est étonnant là
aussi c'est que on a quelqu'un qui est
un élu de la République et qui et qui
pour l'instant n'a pas purger sa peine
qui n'a pas
engagé de travail non plus pour essayer
de se remettre en question moi je
connais pas personnellement Adrien
katmince mais j'ai vu comme beaucoup
sont les hommes peuvent se dire
finalement c'est pas si grave il a été
condamné il revient dans l'hémicycle
c'est que c'est passé justement
l'exemplarité de nos élus on le voit
aussi sur les affaires financières bien
entendu à partir du moment où on est
plus on la peine de mort n'existe plus
c'est une justice qui a vocation à
réintégrer les les condamnés dans la
société mais là on voit qu'il y a pas
grand chose qui a été mis en place et ma
dernière question puisque vous parlez du
taux de récidive est-ce que ces hommes
violents on peut les guérir est-ce qu'on
peut guérir quand on est violent quand
on frappe sa femme voir ses enfants ou
est-ce que c'est un phénomène qui est
irrécupérable non c'est pas récupérable
je pense que c'est très très difficile
quand on commence cette remise en
question et qu'on a déjà 65 ou 70 ans
mais j'ai croisé des et puis il y a des
hommes dans ce livre qui ont entamé un
travail qui essayent de remettre en
question aussi
d'un père extrêmement violent qu'ils ont
peut-être pris en modèle et qui étaient
déjà problématique à l'époque où ils
avaient 10 ou 12 ans et qui aujourd'hui
disent en fait il faut que je change et
cette volonté de changer
associée à un travail justement sur soi
qui permet peut-être d'arriver à un
comportement légèrement différent
peut-être à remettre en question aussi
sa position d'homme dans la famille peut
permettre déjà d'arrêter de frapper ce
qui est déjà la première des priorités
merci Mathieu palan merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous voir je rappelle le
titre de votre livre nos paires nos
frères nos amis dans la tête des hommes
violences c'est une autre manière vous
l'avez compris de voir cette question
des violences conjugales c'est aux
éditions Les Arènes merci merci Mathilde
Fallin d'avoir été avec nous parce que
le club des territoires